today's video is kindly sponsored by
guardio find out more later on hey 42
here for as long as there have been
humans
there's been war
whilst we can hope that a thousand years
from now we'll all have matured into
hoverboard riding pacifists
for the time being murdering each other
in the name of whatever disagreements
fashionable this decade
seems set to remain an intrinsic part of
who we are probably the most devastating
acts of violence ever to have been
carried out by humans on humans were the
atomic bombings of the japanese cities
of hiroshima and nagasaki that's the
tail end of the second world war
the weapons that caused this mass
destruction were code named little boy
and fat man respectively and between
them they claimed somewhere in the
region
of 200 000 lives
the role these two bombs played in
ending the second world war is widely
known but
what's a little less well known is that
this deadly duo was very nearly a trio
whilst the world was still coming to
terms with the sheer level of
devastation little boy and fat man had
unleashed on japan
over in los alamos home of the manhattan
project the finishing touches were being
made to another atomic bomb
had japan not surrendered to the allies
on the 15th of august
this third weapon was penciled in for
being released over an unknown japanese
city just four days later
nestled within the centre of this nuke
that never made it was a radioactive
cord that had been given the nickname
rufus
if that sounds a little too cute for
this explosive core of a city killing
nuclear weapon
don't worry because history has since
given this 6.2 kilogram ball of
plutonium a different name
this is the story
of the demon corps
a bomb that killed despite never being
detonated
now the internet is a wonderful thing
but as the world becomes more connected
the risk of being scammed or hacked
increases with time it's never been more
important to protect yourself whilst
browsing the web and guardio offers that
protection in an effective first line of
defense model detecting threats in real
time before they reach your browser and
cause harm as opposed to traditional
methods that remove them from your
device once they've gained access
researching all these videos often takes
me to very strange corners of the
internet and i come across a lot of
dodgy websites
many of them are there to do me harm
whether it's through phishing attempts
that try to steal my social media or
banking details or fake tech support
scams
so that's why i started using guardio so
i no longer have to think before i click
it was super easy to set up i added the
guardio browser extension then i ran the
free security scan to detect existing
threats
and that's it join over 1 million
guardio users who've taken control of
their online safety and never have to
worry about visiting harmful sites again
to enjoy worry free browsing and run a
free security scan in just a few clicks
to see what threats are on your browser
use my link in the description and
you'll receive an extra discount for the
full browsing protection which includes
a seven day free trial that you can
cancel anytime before the end of the
trial free of charge
don't miss out
when emperor hirohito of japan unfurled
his white flag in the wake of the
bombings of hiroshima and nagasaki
this lump of plutonium that will come to
be known as the demon core was no longer
required for its original deadly purpose
but that didn't make it surplus to
requirements
far from it
the process that gives nuclear weapons
their destructive power nuclear
efficient had been discovered less than
a decade before
that made the demon core a piece of
cutting-edge technology based on brand
new science
that wasn't well understood gaining a
more complete understanding of nuclear
fission had profound implications for
the whole of humankind not only was
there an all too predictable desire to
build bigger and better bombs
nuclear fission could also be put to
less cataclysmic uses
fission occurs when an atom's nucleus is
split in two
a process which releases huge amounts of
energy along with that energy a split
atom also fires out neutrons some of
which in turn will smash into other
atoms splitting them and releasing more
energy and more neutrons under the right
circumstances a self-sustaining chain
reaction can be triggered
unleashing staggering amounts of energy
and i really do mean staggering
fission of a single kilogram of uranium
will produce roughly the same amount of
energy as from burning 4 billion
kilograms of coal
in order to help scientists better
harness this incredible power the demon
core became a subject of study at los
alamos
a vital part of that research involves
so-called criticality experiments
designed to determine under exactly
which conditions a nuclear core will
achieve critical mass the point at which
a self-sustaining nuclear chain reaction
takes place it was important science
understanding critical mass is key to
ensuring your nuclear weapons explode
and your power plants don't
but the experiments were also incredibly
dangerous because figuring out at which
point the demon core would go
supercritical
could only be done by bringing it to the
very edge of a devastating chain
reaction
accidentally triggering such a reaction
wouldn't necessarily lead to an
explosion
but it would unleash a massive wave of
lethal radiation
legendary physicist richard feynman once
famously compared the critical mass
experiments carried out at los alamos to
tikkalinga dragon's tale
his point was clear
make a mistake
and you're going to get burnt
the scientists at los alamos were well
aware of this danger but these were not
cautious men they'd spent the previous
few years developing a weapon that was
capable of single-handedly ending the
biggest war in history whilst millions
of lives were on the line those kinds of
stakes breed urgency and urgency allows
for certain corners to be cut when it
comes to things like safety procedures
and best practices
the end of the war should have taken
that urgency away and allowed for more
caution
but much like bruce willis
old habits die hard now if you picture
scientists carrying out complex
experiments on highly radioactive
materials today you'd probably conjure
images of hazmat suits and heavy lead
doorways covered in alarming yellow and
black symbols
in the 1940s things were a little bit
different
to give you an idea of just how
take a look at this picture
at first glance you'd be forgiven for
thinking these guys are loading a crate
of beer into some beaten up old truck
before a party
but no
in that box is the radioactive plutonium
core that would eventually form the
beating heart of the gadget
the first atomic bomb ever detonated on
earth
that guy in the middle is harry dagliam
by the way a physicist with the
manhattan project and i chose an image
including him
for a reason you see exactly 64 days
after this picture was taken
at just 24 years of age
harry daglian would be dead
dagliam was one of the scientists tasked
with carrying out criticality
experiments at los alamos in the
aftermath of the war
his methodology was fairly simple he
stacked neutron reflecting tungsten
carbide bricks in a ring around the core
this had the effect of bouncing escaping
neutrons back towards the core
therefore increasing the rate of fission
and edging the core closer and closer
towards supercriticality
[Music]
to begin with the experiment was working
well with every tungsten carbide brick
harry stacked his lab instruments
indicated that fission within the core
was increasing but just when the core
was approaching criticality
harry daglian made a mistake
and he woke the dragon
judging that he'd added as many tungsten
carbide bricks as was safe harry reached
out to start dissembling his neutron
reflecting wall
his aim was off by an inch
instead of picking up the topmost brick
he knocked it forwards sending it
tumbling directly on top of the core
which went super critical in an instant
daglian reacted immediately grabbing the
errant brick and tossing it away he was
fast
but not fast enough
a blast of ionizing radiation had
already crashed into his body with such
force
it had damaged his dna
acute radiation sickness doesn't kill
you instantly it takes time for the
catastrophic cell level damage it causes
to make itself known
typically it starts with flu-like
symptoms nausea vomiting and diarrhea
oddly enough sufferers usually rally at
this point and for a period that can
last hours or even weeks
they present relatively few symptoms
but that's just the calm before the
storm
exactly how things go next it depends on
the dosage of radiation perceived
but symptoms include confusion seizures
tremors blistered skin hemorrhaging
fever
and organ failure harry daglian
experienced his own miserable cocktail
of these symptoms over the following 25
days
before finally slipping away
in doing so he became the first person
in history to die in a nuclear
criticality accident
fast forward nine months and the demon
corps had been lined up for a new
assignment as part of operation
crossroads
the united states first post-nuclear war
weapons tests that were scheduled to
take place at bikini atoll in the middle
of the pacific ocean
knowing that the demon core would soon
be gone for good the scientists at los
alamos were keen to extract as much data
from it as possible whilst they still
had the chance
and that meant more criticality
experiments
you'd think that seeing a colleague die
horribly carrying out one of these
experiments
would have been enough to catalyze some
fairly robust safety reforms at los
alamos but yeah
they didn't bother with any of that
canadian physicist louis slaughton was
considered to be pretty much the world's
leading expert when it came to tickling
the dragon's tail and he led many of the
criticality experiments in the lead up
to operation crossroads
considered to be something of a maverick
by his colleagues at los alamos slauson
usually rocked up to work in his
trademark blue jeans and cowboy boots as
a bit of an exhibitionist he
particularly enjoyed tickling the
dragon's tale in front of an audience
yeah okay that came out wrong
anyway there were seven other scientists
in attendance for the final criticality
experiment before the demon core was to
be shipped off to the pacific
instead of piling tungsten carbide
bricks around the core as douglian had
slotted encased it inside two
hemispheres of neutron-reflecting
beryllium
in theory the experiment should have
been relatively safe
so long as a gap was maintained between
the two hemispheres at all times
enough neutrons would be able to escape
to ensure the core would never go
supercritical
to that end the experiment was usually
run using spacers that physically
prevented the beryllium hemispheres from
meeting
but slotten's setup didn't use spaces
because he'd invented his own
state-of-the-art alternative
a screwdriver that's right as utterly
ridiculous as it may sound
when louis slotten tickled the dragon's
tail
all that stood between him and the
demon's core radioactive breath was the
whiff of a flathead screwdriver wedged
casually between the beryllium
reflectors
despite the danger slosson had carried
out the experiment in exactly this way
dozens of times before
but
on the 21st of may 1946 exactly nine
months to the day after harry daglian
had woken the dragon
slotten's screwdriver slipped
the beryllium hemispheres briefly met
fully enclosing the demon core and
igniting a nuclear chain reaction
within a burst of bright blue light was
followed by a wave of heat as the demon
core belched four for colossal blast of
radiation
just as harry daglian had nine months
before
louis slotten reacted fast flipping the
upper hemisphere free from the core
but
once again it was much
much too late
it's kind of terrifying to think what
must have been going through slotten's
head in those frantic seconds
he was one of the world's leading
experts on the handling of plutonium and
he just seen a colleague and friend
die horribly in a similar accident mere
mumps beforehand
he knew exactly what he'd just done
and more importantly he knew exactly
what was going to happen next
according to one of the other scientists
in the room at the time slotten spoke
exactly four words in the immediate
aftermath of the accident
well
that does it
it's estimated that slotten received a
dose of radiation so high it would have
been fatal four times over
in some ways
that was a blessing whilst harry daglian
had clung onto life for close to a month
louis slotten was dead within nine days
[Music]
i won't go into the details of his
decline because to be frank
it's harrowing stuff
let's just say
it wasn't a good way to go
as for the seven other scientists in the
room at the time
each received a different dose of
radiation depending on where they've
been sitting or standing at the time of
the accident
you may be assuming that anyone unlucky
enough to have been nearby was a dead
man walking but radioactive emissions
are governed by the inverse square law
meaning the intensity of radiation drops
off rapidly the further away you get
from the source
nobody aside from slotten suffered from
acute radiation sickness in the
aftermath of the accident though at
least two of those presents died years
later from radiation related causes
as a result of the criticality accident
that killed louis slotten the demon core
was too radioactive to be used in
operation crossroads as had been planned
and in the end it was simply melted down
and reintegrated into the us's nuclear
arsenal
which means it's very possible that
elements of this killer core
sit inside other nuclear weapons within
the u.s stockpile to this day
when you think about it there's a kind
of tragic irony to this already sad
story
free bombs were assembled to be dropped
on japan at the end of the second world
war the first killed 140 000 people in
hiroshima
the second killed 80 000 in nagasaki the
third
it killed two in-cautious scientists
working at los alamos and it's that one
that earns the nickname
the demon core
thanks for watching